Donald Trump lied for five uninterrupted minutes
during yesterday's Corona virus press briefing
about vote by mail. The question came from
right wing propaganda network O.J. in the
way that the O.J. and questions typically
work. Is that O.J.? And we'll set up some
completely distorted softball question for
Donald Trump or his press secretary, Kaley
McEnany. Sometimes the question itself is
so disjointed that you can actually see confusion
on the face of the O.J. and reporter asking
the question. Like sometimes the reporter
doesn't understand the question. They seem
confused by their own question. And it's just
basically like a carte blanche for Donald
Trump or Kaley Makani to start ranting and
raving about whatever is on their agenda.
This time the question was about what vote
by mail and whether Trump would do anything
at the federal level to stop vote by mail.
And Donald Trump, five minutes. Going, going,
going. Lying, lying. Lying. Let's jump right
into it.
O n. O n. Thank you, Mr. President and Indonesia,
two hundred and forty three year history,
there has never been a stronger push, mainly
not determined in national action. We are
considering at any point issuing an executive
order addressing really dies down. Why do
you think some people are pushing aside?
Well, there's never been a push like this
for mail in ballots. And if you look at the
New York congressional race, which is a disaster,
Carolyn, it's been a total disaster. They
have they're six weeks into it now. They have
no clue what's going on. And I mean, I think
I can say right here and now, I think you
have to rerun that race because it's a mess.
Nobody knows what's happening with the ballots
and the lost ballots and the fraudulent ballots,
I guess. I think you'd probably have to take
the Carolyn Maloney race and run it over again.
How can you do this? And this is a small race
with literally thousands of people, small
thousands. And it's all messed up. You look
at Patterson, New Jersey, it's all messed
up. Almost every one of these. And these are
small, easy to control. They should be able
to do this easy. Now, you're talking about
like Nevada, where last two nights ago they
they went out in the darkness of night without
people, without having any meetings of the
public, without having anything. They approved
a ridiculous. You don't have to look at signatures.
You don't have to approve anything. You can
have double mailings.
So we're 90 seconds in here, not even. And
Trump is lying uncontrollable. He's claiming
that what Nevada did is somehow pernicious.
I'll talk about that later. He's talking about,
you know, you can have double mailings. You
don't need signatures. None of that is true.
Nevada approved sending absentee ballots to
registered voters who went through the normal
process for voter registration. If he did
it at the Registry of Motor Vehicles, they
have your signature. It was the appropriate
process. There are other opportunities, of
course, to register to vote. You have to be
a citizen. All of that stuff applies. It's
just sending ballots to registered voters.
Let's keep going.
You can have all sorts of things. Nobody's
ever seen anything like it. It's a disgrace.
I mean, honestly, it's a disgrace. So it's
a very good question. I mean, the mail in
ballots, if you look at just some of the small,
the small places, the small races, a congressional
race in New York should be very easy. Normally,
that would have been announced at seven o'clock
and it would have been down to the wire and
everybody would have loved it. It was it was
at all complex. It would have taken an extra
45 minutes or an hour. They would have announced
it a little bit later. They have no clue.
This was about six weeks ago and they have
no clue what's going on. They've lost ballots.
There's fraudulent ballots. It's how are you
going to do that for an entire nation?
Now, it is true that the New York situation
is not good, but the problem is not an issue
of fraud. It's a logistical problem. And it
relates to postmarks and last minute mailings
by the city of New York. This doesn't excuse
the problem. There are problems around the
country. Whenever we have a presidential election
with in-person voting, voter suppression,
voter rolls, all of this stuff and many of
those problems are by design. There are concerns
here, legitimate ones, and we have similar
concerns about in-person voting as well. But
this is all fixable stuff and Trump is framing
it all as proactive fraud. The post office
has said they are more than equipped to handle
the volume of ballots that's expected in the
fall. But Trump is trying to kneecap the post
office. So in other words, Trump is trying
to cause problems rather than solve them and
then point to the problems he plans to exacerbate
as reasons why we shouldn't do expanded absentee
ballot access, which is essentially what we're
talking about. No, you know, Trump's trying
to create this false distinction between vote
by mail and absentee ballot. And while in
theory there could be two different things
in practice for November. We're talking about
expanding absentee.
Let's continue using cover to try and get
the mail in ballots. Now, absentee ballots
are great absentee ballots after request them.
They go through a process, they get them.
But the universal mail in ballots have turned
out to be a disaster. And what Nevada has
been doing, if you look over the last few
days, you have to look at what they've done.
You can have two ballots. You can harvest.
It's harvesting so you can take thousands
of ballots, put them together and just dump
them down on somebodies desk after a certain
period of time. They have something where
if you vote, the vote can count up to seven
days later. Well, if the vote's going to count
seven days later, that means, you know, if
it if it depends on the one state like Nevada,
that would mean simply that you can't have.
Supposing it's down to that one state, it
could be a great state. But supposing it's
down to that one state, that means you have
to wait seven days.
Again, absentee versus vote by mail. The request
process, et cetera. We're talking here about
letting anybody vote absentee. Who wants to?
That's what we're talking about. It's not
a new system. And I'm going to keep repeating
this endlessly because it has been debunked.
It is a distinction that doesn't really exist
in practice.
And then Trump goes to again, you might not
know the results on election night. So what?
So what Trump is saying both that it's going
to be rigged. And he wants the results right
away. Well, is it the worst thing in the world?
If it took a few days and we were sure that
we got the right results that account for
the absentee ballots. And we know every vote
has been counted. It doesn't sound so bad.
Let's keep going.
But they want to have it there. This is something
that's so messed up. And by the way, I have
to say, the post office for many, many years
has been, you know, run in a fashion that
hasn't been great, great workers and everything.
But they have old equipment, very old equipment.
And I don't think the post office is prepared
for a thing like this. You have to ask the
people at the post office. But how can the
post office be expected to handle they have
regular mailing and then now on top of that,
they have the Internet where you have Amazon
and these companies doing all the buying instead
of going to a department store, they go by
through mail. So you have massive numbers
of purchases now going through the post office
purchases of items and gifts. And that's a
tremendous strain on the post office. The
post office loses a fortune. It has been for
many, many years, for decades. So now on top
of it, it has this and the Amazons of the
world and the others, they pay very, very
little money. They lose money on every the
post office loses money, which is ridiculous
on every package it delivers. But now, on
top of that, and I'm not just referring to
Amazon, I'm talking about all of the competitors.
If there is such a thing to Amazon, there
will be David Pakman.
So while he's weighing in on e-commerce trends
there, Donald Trump also throws in that the
post office couldn't handle the volume of
mail in votes. Again, the post office has
said we can handle it just fine. They've put
out a statement saying so. But Donald Trump
wants to prevent them from being able to handle
it by cutting their funding, which is what
his new postmaster general seems determined
to do. Lewis Dejoy, who is a Trump donor and
Trump is still going. He's still ranting and
lying here.
But if there is such a thing. But now on top
of that, you'll have somebody like the governor
of Nevada come out with his massive plan out
of nowhere to take millions of ballots and
send them all over the place. He'll never
know who won that state. It'll get messed
up, just like New York and just like Patterson,
New Jersey, and just like many other places
in West Virginia. They indicted a a postman
for doing something very bad. You know that.
And but there are many cases all over the
country. If you look, you'll be able to fund
there's a list of all over the country and
that has to do with universal mail.
Now, this is important when Trump and others
cite the few examples of actual mail in ballot
fraud. Those are people who got caught. The
system worked. The people didn't get away
with it. There are very few examples. And
the people got caught. That means that the
fraud was not something they got away with.
It was attempted fraud which was caught. This
is like saying smoke detectors sometimes detect
a house fire. So we shouldn't build houses
because they're not safe. No, no, no, no.
The smoke detector worked, which allows us
to safely have the houses five minutes straight
of lie after lie after lie, thanks to a softball
question from Trump friendly media sycophants
in the back of the room. It's not dissimilar
from North Korean propaganda. Now, getting
to the end of this again, I mean, it's just
exhausting with the vote by mail versus absentee.
Again, absentee is great. It works like in
Florida. They'll do absentee. It really works.
But universal mail in ballots is going to
be a great embarrassment to our country. The
right to do it. We haven't gotten there yet.
But we'll see what happens. We will be suing
in Nevada and that's already been taken care
of, will probably file something tomorrow.
I do want to say that we're going to be introducing
a tremendous health care plan sometime prior,
hopefully prior to the end of the month. It's
just about completed now.
And that's the final point. Trump apparently
does think he can just make a presidential
decree about vote by mail, but he can't remember
that states run their own elections. They
can do as they please within the law. Trump
can try to sue, but he can't just cancel vote
by mail from the Oval Office. Notice, by the
way, Trump does bring up at the end there
his new health care plan supposedly that was
going to be signed into law 48 hours ago.
Now, he says it will be signed into law by
the end of August. That should really be a
hoot. So five straight minutes of lying.
We'll have more of this on our Instagram page,
David Pakman show on Instagram. Follow us
there after the break. How to vote by mail.
It's not tough. It's really not difficult.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.